Ce sont les pompiers, les urgentistes, les patients atteints de cancer,
les travailleurs humanitaires, les réfugiés --
quiconque exposé à un traumatisme ou un stress majeur dans sa vie.
Pourtant, malgré le fait que ces maladies soient courantes,
nos traitements actuels, s'ils fonctionnent,
ne font qu'éradiquer les symptômes.
En 1798, quand Edward Jenner a découvert le premier vaccin --
celui pour la variole --
il n'a pas découvert qu'un médicament prophylactique pour une maladie
mais une nouvelle manière de penser :
les médicaments pouvaient prévenir les maladies.
Cependant, pendant plus de 200 ans,
on n'a pas cru que cette prévention s'étendait aux maladies psychiatriques.
Jusqu'à 2014, quand mon collègue et moi avons accidentellement découvert
les premiers médicaments qui pourraient prévenir la dépression et le TSPT.
Nous les avons découverts chez les souris
et nous étudions actuellement leurs effets chez les êtres humains.
Ces psychotropes préventifs
ne sont pas des antidépresseurs.
C'est une nouvelle classe de médicaments.
Ils fonctionnent en augmentant la résilience au stress,
appelons-les agents amplificateurs de la résilience.
Repensez à une période stressante dont vous vous êtes remis.
Peut-être une rupture, un examen ou un avion manqué.
La résilience au stress est un processus biologique actif
qui nous permet de rebondir après du stress.
Comme quand vous avez un rhume et votre système immunitaire le combat.
Une résilience insuffisante
face à un facteur de stress important
peut résulter en un trouble psychiatrique tel que la dépression.
La majorité des cas des troubles dépressifs importants
sont initialement déclenchés par du stress.
De ce que j'ai observé chez les souris,
les agents amplificateurs de la résilience
peuvent protéger des facteurs de stress biologiques,
tels que les hormones du stress,
et des facteurs de stress sociaux et psychologiques,
tels que le harcèlement et l'isolement.
Voici un exemple où nous avons donné aux souris
trois semaines avec beaucoup d'hormones du stress.
En d'autres mots, un facteur de stress biologique sans composante psychologique.
Cela entraîne un comportement dépressif.
Si nous donnons auparavant trois semaines de traitement antidépresseur,
cela n'a pas d'effets bénéfiques.
Mais une seule dose d'un agent amplificateur de la résilience
donnée une semaine auparavant
évite entièrement le comportement dépressif.
Même après trois semaines de stress.
C'est la première fois que l'on a montré qu'un médicament
prévenait les effets négatifs du stress.
La dépression et le TSPT sont des maladies chroniques,
souvent permanentes, cliniques.
Elles augmentent aussi les risques de toxicomanie, d'être sans abri,
de maladies cardiaques, d'Alzheimer, de suicide.
A lui seul, le coût mondial de la dépression
est de plus de trois mille milliards de dollars par an.
Mais imaginez un scénario où nous prévoyons quand quelqu'un
a un risque élevé d'exposition à un stress extrême.
Disons un bénévole de la Croix-Rouge allant dans une zone de séisme.
En plus du vaccin pour la typhoïde,
nous pourrions lui donner un cachet ou une injection
d'un agent amplificateur de la résilience avant son départ.
Quand il sera sous la menace de pillards ou pire,
il sera protégé contre le développement d'une dépression ou d'un TSPT
après les faits.
Cela ne lui évitera pas de ressentir le stress,
mais cela lui permettra de s'en remettre.
C'est ce qui est révolutionnaire.
En augmentant la résilience,
nous pouvons dramatiquement réduire
sa susceptibilité à la dépression et au TSPT,
évitant possiblement qu'il ne perde son travail,
sa maison, sa famille ou même sa vie.
Après que Jenner ait découvert le vaccin contre la variole,
beaucoup d'autres vaccins ont rapidement suivi.
Mais il a fallu plus de 150 ans
avant que le vaccin contre la tuberculose ne soit largement disponible.
Pourquoi ?
En partie car la société croyait
que la tuberculose rendait les gens plus sensibles, créatives, empathiques.
Et que sa cause était naturelle et non biologique.
On dit encore des choses similaires au sujet de la dépression.
Tout comme la découverte de Jenner a ouvert la porte
à tous les vaccins qui ont suivi,
les médicaments que nous avons découverts
offrent la possibilité d'un nouveau domaine :
la psychopharmacologie préventive.
Mais que cela arrive dans 15 ans
ou dans 150 ans
ne dépend pas que de la science
mais de ce que nous choisissons d'en faire en tant que société.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)